aux portes de l'église du saint sépulcre
des fidèles privés de metz cette année
la liturgie de pâques s'est déroulée à
huis clos en raison du coronavirus mais
pour cette poignée de croyants la foi
religieuse a été plus forte que la
raison sanitaire c'est notre religion ce
sont nos traditions nous venons ici tous
les ans et cela n'est jamais arrivé dans
la vie j'ai transgressé les règles pour
venir ici parce que je les fais pour
dieu j'aime ce passage de la bible qui
dit l'amour parfait chasse la peur et
oui nous ne vous être prudent mais le
fait est que dieu fera ressortir le
meilleur de tout cela
habituellement la basilique accueille
plusieurs centaines de fidèles à pâques
mais ce dimanche seule une petite
dizaine de religieux se trouvaient à
l'intérieur pour célébrer cette messe si
particulière le frère stéphane qui
étaient présents appelle les fidèles à
respecter les mesures de confinement
pour freiner la pandémie votre foi en la
résurrection vous fait savoir qu'après
la mort il y aura une vie éternelle
il ne s'agit pas d'anticiper les
échéances est donc aujourd'hui il faut
être prudent
nous sommes tristes que les pèlerins ne
puisse pas venir mais il faut il faut
respecter les normes de sécurité et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
célébré la messe de pâques en n'étant
pas tellement nombreux
mais il faut très vite on aimerait être
prudent il faut que cette pandémie
puis cesser le plus tôt possible pour
que la vie puisse repartir pour le mieux
dans le dé plus de révéler en attendant
dans toute la vieille ville de jérusalem
les rues étaient désertes et les
magasins et restaurants fermés dans le
quartier juif
les croyants sont eux aussi en pleine
pessah la pâque juive
quant aux musulmans il se prépare pour
le ramadan qui débutera dans une dizaine
de jours